- [Interviewer] Let me
put a microphone on you.
There we go. They go under your arm.
Hey, Andrea.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] How are you?
- Uh, I'm feelin' okay today.
Not...
- [Interviewer] Welcome back.
- Not good, not bad, just okay.
- [Interviewer] Just okay is good.
So we were just talking
about your mental disorder.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about that again.
- I'm bipolar with psychotic features.
I can have mood swings,
I can get depressed,
and I also have the
psychotic temper problem.
- [Interviewer] And you
think this was from something
that happened to you,
or you think you were...
- No, I was actually,
I'm actually this way.
I've always been that way all my life.
- [Interviewer] Born with it.
- Yeah, born with it.
- [Interviewer] Anyone else
in your family have this?
- I think so 'cause it
musta been hereditary.
I was born with it.
I was born with it,
and other people in my
family had tempers like mine.
- [Interviewer] Oh, they did?
- Yeah. Yep.
- [Interviewer] How would you
describe your personality,
your disorder, or your mental situation.
How would you describe it?
- Oh.
It doesn't bother me very frequently,
but when it bothers me, it bothers me.
- [Interviewer] And
how does it bother you?
What does it do? It makes you...
- When it's doing its thing,
(stutters) that bothers me.
You know, the mood swings,
and being depressed,
or being too angry.
Being overly angry.
(mumbling indistinctly)
It doesn't me frequently,
but when it bothers me,
it bothers me.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
stuff happens when it does?
- Well, just how I feel.
Basically how I feel.
Well, if I feel angry, I'll bother others.
That's when it bothers
others, when I'm angry.
- [Interviewer] So the
drugs that are down here,
you smoke spice sometimes?
- Yeah. I smoke spice everyday.
- [Interviewer] You do?
And is it the spice that makes
you the way you are today,
or is this your personality disorder?
- Oh no, this is my personality
when I'm not having any
problems with my disorder.
This is my personality
when my disorder isn't bothering me.
- [Interviewer] When everything's cool.
- Right, when everything's cool.
- [Interviewer] And
you're not smoking spice.
- Spice helps me like marajuana
for eating and sleeping.
- [Interviewer] Helps you what?
- Spice helps me like marajuana
for eating and sleeping.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see. I see.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] So right
now, you're not high?
- No I'm not, I haven't
had anything today yet.
- [Interviewer] And you're
not having your issues,
your mental issues?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] You're not
having any mental issues
flaring up today?
- No, not today.
- [Interviewer] This is just,
this is Andrea at her...
- Yeah, I'm just Andrea today.
- [Interviewer] Cool.
(Andrea laughs)
- [Interviewer] (chuckles) So,
where are you sleeping now?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Where
are you sleeping now?
- Oh, I sleep in the same place.
I'm John Boston's tenant
on the ground floor of the
Continental over on Towne Avenue.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you
stay in the Continental Hotel?
- On the ground floor.
I'm John Boston's tenant.
I'm on the ground floor on Towne Avenue.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you're in a tent?
- No, I'm not in a tent.
I'm John Boston's tenant.
- [Interviewer] Oh,
you're John Boston's...
- I'm John Boston's tenant.
I live on the ground floor.
- [Interviewer] I got it.
At the Continental Hotel.
- I don't live in the upstairs hotel part.
I live on the ground floor.
I'm the manager's tenant.
- [Interviewer] And there
is a hotel room for you?
- I...
- [Interviewer] You're
staying in a hotel room?
- I just have a room. I just have a room.
No sink, no bathroom, no shower.
I have to shower upstairs.
- [Interviewer] It's a private room?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] That's nice.
Nobody's giving you a hard time there?
- Right, it's a nice, warm and
safe place to live and sleep.
(hands slapping)
- [Interviewer] Which
is a big deal down here.
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] That's
a big deal down here.
- Yeah, it is.
- [Interviewer] And how
do you spend your days,
your typical day?
Like today you... it's
fairly early in the morning,
and you...
- I don't really every do...
I don't really ever do anything special.
- [Interviewer] What do you do, though?
You wake up, and you'll
have breakfast, no?
- No.
I don't ever do anything
special, just living.
To me, that's just normal life.
- [Interviewer] But living is, what?
You are walking around looking...
(indistinct) Going places.
Walk to places to go get things.
Eating and...
You know, just...
It's just normal things. I
don't do anything special.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any money saved up?
- No, I don't.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have a dime to your name?
- I get a check, and I pay my landlord.
I pay my landlord.
They control my money for me
'cause I'm not good with money.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
So you give them your check,
the money from your...
- I get a little bit... I
have some money everyday.
But I have a little bit of money everyday.
- [Interviewer] And he gives you
a little bit of money everyday?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's nice of him.
- I get $10 every day.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- I get 20 on the first.
- [Interviewer] How much?
- Right, after my rent,
I get 20 on the first,
and I get $10 every day after that.
- [Interviewer] $10 is enough to get by?
- And I get $20 on the first,
and I get $10 a day for the
rest of the month after that
after my rent.
- [Interviewer] Is this
why you smoke spice
'cause it's so inexpensive?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Is this
why you smoke spice
because it's very inexpensive?
- No. I smoke spice because I love it.
(interviewer chuckles)
(Andrea chuckles)
- [Interviewer] What's spice do for you?
- That's pot for me. That's pot to me.
- [Interviewer] But spice is not pot.
Spice is a much...
- I know, it's a poison,
but that what it does to me.
It's like pot for me.
- [Interviewer] And what
is the hallucinatory effect
from spice?
- I don't hallucinate.
- [Interviewer] What do
you do? You pass out?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Most people just pass out.
- I pass out on my back.
(snores)
- [Interviewer] That's good.
That's safer than anywhere else.
- That's right.
- [Interviewer] These people
pass out on the street,
and they get robbed, right?
- (indistinct) It makes me eat.
It helps me eat. Like
marajuana. (chuckles)
(indistinct) when I'm having
it, it'll help me eat.
It helps me eat.
- [Interviewer] I get it.
And do you have any friends?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- I have. I have a couple.
I don't have that many. I (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] I'm
sorry, what is the story
with your family?
You still have your mom?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Your...
- My family's dead and gone.
- [Interviewer] Okay, I forget. I'm sorry.
- I'm by myself now.
- [Interviewer] All by yourself.
- That's right, all by myself now.
I don't have any relatives living.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- I'm 45, I'm about to be
46 in September on the 18th.
September 18th, I'm gonna be 46.
I look pretty good for my age, huh?
- [Interviewer] You do.
You do.
So what, I mean, what do you see
the rest of your life looking like?
What are you gonna do?
Got any plans, anything
you'd like to see different,
or does anything happen
that you'd like to see?
- Ah.
- [Interviewer] Or you
just want to survive?
- I'd like to become a nurse.
I'd like to go back to
school and become a nurse.
I'm tired of doing nothing with my life.
I'd like to become a nurse.
- [Interviewer] That'd be cool.
- Uh.
- [Interviewer] Have you been to college?
- No, I haven't, I didn't
graduate high school.
I haven't made anything out of myself.
I wanna go back to school.
I would like to become a nurse.
- [Interviewer] Yeah well, I'd
like to be an astronaut too,
but that ain't gonna happen.
- Right. (lightly chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Yeah, a little
reality sometimes is good.
- Right, right, right.
- [Interviewer] A little
reality check might be helpful.
- That's right.
- [Interviewer] So, a nurse
is maybe not in the cards
since you haven't even
finished high school,
but is there anything in your life
that you'd like to maybe change?
You're fine with where you live?
- [Andrea] I have to move
away from this area some day.
- [Interviewer] That would be great.
That's a goal I can (chuckles) I could see
being worth while.
That's doable, and that
would be helpful too, right?
That'd be cool to be
outta Skid Row, right?
- [Andrea] Ah.
- [Interviewer] Would
you ever come back here?
- [Andrea] Probably not. I don't think so.
- [Interviewer] That's a good answer.
(chuckling)
There's only one reason to come down here.
- [Andrea] Right (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] If you
wanna self destruct.
- [Andrea] Right.
- [Interviewer] That's
it. No other reason.
- [Andrea] (indistinct) up.
- [Interviewer] Unless you're
a nut like me. (chuckles)
(Andrea laughs)
So, no family.
- [Andrea] No.
- [Interviewer] Very few friends.
- [Andrea] Right.
- [Interviewer] And
you're livin' on Skid Row.
And you've been here how many years?
- [Andrea] I've been living
here since December 23, 2002.
I've been at the Continental
since September 1st, '04.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
- [Andrea] That's how
long I been downtown for.
Since December 23, 2002.
- [Interviewer] And I'm sure
you've seen some crazy stuff
down here.
Has anything bad happened to you
while you've been down here
for a couple of decades?
- [Andrea] Huh?
- [Interviewer] Has
anything bad happened to you
in the couple decades you've been here?
- Um, not particularly.
Not particularly.
- [Interviewer] Nobody's robbed
you, raped you, hurt you?
- Um, no.
- [Interviewer] No? Good for you.
People leave you alone mostly?
- Yeah. I like it that way.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I don't blame you.
- (indistinct) Just leave
me alone. (laughing)
When I'm walking around places
getting what I want or need, or whatever,
I prefer to be just left alone.
Don't bother me.
- [Interviewer] What's your view on life?
I mean, do you see
human existence as...
I mean, do you see other people
as good natured and kind,
or do you see people as a
bunch of cutthroat snakes
that are tryna take advantage of you?
- Some of both.
- [Interviewer] Some of both.
- (chuckling) Oh, some of both.
- [Interviewer] Good answer.
That's exactly right.
(Andrea chuckling)
And everybody's got a
little bit of both, right?
- The nice ones are the
ones I wanna talk to.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Like you.
- [Interviewer] Are there
a whole lot down here?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Are there many
of those people down here?
- What?
- [Interviewer] Kind people.
- Kind people? There's plenty
of nice people around here.
- [Interviewer] There are.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
no I think you're right.
I think there are.
But they're still down here doing things
that are probably not the
best things to be doing.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] If you coulda changed
one thing about your life,
what do you think you would've changed?
Something probably from your childhood?
- Uh, I woulda graduated from high school,
and went to college.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hm, that's helpful.
What about the stuff that
happened with your...
Was it your dad, or stepdad
when you were a kid?
- Oh, yeah. Oh, that. (sighs)
- [Interviewer] That mighta changed
the direction of your life, right?
- No, I don't think that woulda changed
the direction of my life.
That doesn't help.
Uh, that hasn't been...
That hasn't been...
That hasn't determined any
of the rest of my life after that.
If I could do something different
in the past where it belongs at,
I woulda graduated from
school, and went to college.
- [Interviewer] Good
for you. That's great.
Yeah, education is great.
- Yeah. Are we about done?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, we're about done.
Tell me one crazy thing about
your life that I don't know.
What do most people not know about Andrea?
- Uh.
- [Interviewer] Is there
anything about you that...
- I'm a hermaphrodite.
- [Interviewer] You are?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Cut it out.
- No, really. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] What
do you have down there?
- In front of my uterus
is where my penis is.
It's on top of my uterus.
- [Interviewer] For real?
- Right here.
- [Interviewer] So, do
you consider yourself
a man or a woman?
- I'm women with some
mister equipment extra.
- [Interviewer] You got
some extra equipment.
- Right.
I got the male equipment
extra on top of being a woman.
- [Interviewer] So to be
sexually satisfied, do you...
(Andrea chuckling)
- Ideal for me, I would have a wife.
- [Interviewer] Really?
(Andrea laughing)
So, you have a penis, or a small
penis, or what do you have?
(Andrea inhales and chuckles)
- (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- I don't know how God hides it in here.
- [Interviewer] But
you have a large penis?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Really?
Wow. That's so cool.
(Andrea sighs)
I'm sorry. Is that embarrassing for you?
(Andrea laughs)
I think it's kind of interesting.
- Cool.
- [Interviewer] I don't judge.
- I like it. I'm happy.
- [Interviewer] (chuckles)
It's gotta be fun, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] (chuckles)
Were you pickin' up guys
for dates at one point in
your life, or do you still?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Do you
pick up guys to make money,
you know, pick up...
- No, I don't live my life like that.
I don't live my life that way.
- [Interviewer] Gonna say,
that be one hell of a surprise
for a guy.
- I quit doing that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, wow. Good for you.
Has that effected your life?
I mean, like, growing up that way,
do you think that was
something that impacted
the direction of your life?
Like the relationships you had,
the romantic relationships.
I'm sure it must've effected that, right?
- No.
Huh.
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever been in love?
- Yeah. I'm a widow.
When I was...
I got married when I was
18, and my husband was 50.
I'm a widow.
- [Interviewer] Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How was your marriage?
- Huh?
- Oh, it was mostly good.
It was mostly good.
- [Interviewer] When you say mostly,
what were the bad parts?
- Oh, we had a little bit of
abuse in our relationship.
- [Interviewer] You know me,
I like the dirty parts. (chuckles)
(Andrea laughs)
I like the dirt.
- 'Cause he liked to
pick fist fights with me.
- [Interviewer] He liked to
get fist fights with you?
- No, my husband used to like
to pick fist fights with me
now and then.
- [Interviewer] And he
used to beat you up.
- No, I used to beat
him up. He started it.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- He musta liked it. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Oh, wow.
Somethin' for everybody.
- He musta liked gettin'
his ass beat by his wife.
- [Interviewer] (chuckles)
Some people are into that.
- Not shit. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Wow, that's
very interesting, Andrea.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, you...
You see yourself as a female?
- Yeah. Oh, that's just extra equipment.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but
you get like an erection
like a male would have.
- Yes, I do. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] But
you have a vagina, too.
- Yes. I have both.
- [Interviewer] Can I use my favorite joke
that I get crucified for on this channel?
- What?
- [Interviewer] What're
you doin' later? (laughs)
(Andrea laughing)
I wanna see what you're all about.
I'm actually joking, I don't.
But, that's very interesting.
I mean, do you...
I've never talked to...
I've never met a hermaphrodite
before, I don't think.
- Ah.
- [Interviewer] Or, no one's
that admitted it to me.
That's pretty interesting.
I mean, do you see it
as a plus or a minus?
- Oh, a plus.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I'll bet.
(Andrea gasps)
You can have sex with yourself.
- (laughs) I could, but I haven't.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
I'm just joking, I'm...
- I should try it.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry if I'm making...
- [Interviewer] You should.
(Andrea chuckles)
Not right here.
- Oh, well fuck yourself.
You know what? I think I will. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] It's
not that kinda channel.
- Someone tells me,
"Oh, go fuck yourself."
You know what? Good idea.
(interviewer laughing)
I think I will. (laughing)
- [Interviewer] You're funny.
You're funny, Andrea.
Cool, well thank you so
much for talkin' with me.
I'm so glad I asked
you that crazy question
'cause your answer was 10
times crazier than I expected.
(Andrea laughs)
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right, darlin'.
- All right.
- [Interviewer] We're gonna
make your day a little better.
- All right. Yeah, I'm havin' a good day.
- [Interviewer] All right, darlin'.
- Nice talkin' to you. I love doing that.
- [Interviewer] You can
come back another time.
(Andrea exclaims)
- [Interviewer] I'd love to see you.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I'm glad
you showed up today.
(Andrea gasps and sighs)
- [Interviewer] That was fun.
- [Andrea] Yeah, it was.
- [Interviewer] I'll take this off ya.